what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing a pretty crazy theory in boku
no hero a theory that if true could
absolutely shatter everything we thought
we knew about all for one
the nomu and all mites former master
nana Shimura this theory is so crazy
that even though it first popped into my
head months ago I honestly felt that it
was too out there to be turned into a
video but then I saw a bunch of comments
on my other MHA videos talking about the
exact same theory and so I thought hey
if I'm not the only one having these
thoughts and people in the comments are
requesting for me to talk about it maybe
I should make a video after all
basically it's not my fault you guys
commented and requested the video so you
made me do it
seriously though this theory is a lot of
fun to think about and recent chapters
of the manga have definitely given a bit
more credence to this theory as new
potential evidence has emerged so I will
talk about all of that right here let's
get into it if you enjoyed the book
window hero videos on this channel you
want us to keep it go and please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you have it to be new to anime
uproar or you just haven't subscribed
yet please consider subscribing and
hitting that notification bell to turn
on all notifications a huge thank you to
all of our anime our patrons who support
makes videos like this one possible
especially during these difficult times
I will talk more about patreon at the
end of the video but first please be
advised that this video will contain
boku no hero manga spoilers the theory
itself is not a spoiler because it's
certainly not confirmed it's just a
theory
but in order to examine the theory I
have to talk about all the latest
information in the manga so this video
will contain boku no hero manga spoilers
please proceed with caution you have
been warned so as soon as the female
high end nomu also known as the woman
normal was first introduced in the manga
back in like chapter two to one she
struck me as unique and potentially
important
she is the only nomu that we've seen
with clearly visible breasts implying
that she could be the only female nomu
in existence she also has a very strong
athletic build which could mean that the
human whose body was used to create this
gnome was also athletic but that's only
speculation since it is possible that
the Noma fication process altered her
body so yeah when she was first
introduced as one of the dozen high ends
inside a logical secret lab I thought
that she was interesting but that's
about it
it was only after the big kudo giddy
reveal many chapters later that I first
started thinking about the possibility
that the female nomu is even more unique
than we realize
you will recall that after his arrest
and imprisonment in Tartarus the heroes
discovered that kuru kuru was a nomu
created from the corpse of Oboro
shirokuma
the former classmate and close personal
friend of Aizawa and present mike now
the thing about Oboro is that he was
allegedly killed some fourteen years
earlier during a battle against the
villain his friends present mike and i
zihua were devastated by the loss but
they didn't know about the even darker
truth a truth that was revealed to them
only after kuru gary's capture it turns
out that all for one a new gqo managed
to get their hands on a burrows body
probably through Lucas connections in
the hospital where his body was taken
the two villains then used a burrows
body as a base in order to create the
nomu known as kuru giri and obelisk work
cloud was used as a base to create
Karakas quark warp gate this shocky
revealed that kuru Gideon was actually
Oboro got me thinking how is it possible
that kudo kitty was made so long ago and
yet he is so intelligent
that we didn't even realize that he was
actually a normal for much of the story
we know that the vast majority of normal
lack even basic intelligence and the
high end no moon the ones who are
actually intelligent and capable of
speech have only been introduced
recently they were basically introduced
like fourteen years after Kudo Geary was
apparently
created my theory is that Oboro may not
have been a corpse at all that perhaps
he was alive when his body was used to
create kuru Gilly and so I am
speculating that the fact that he was
alive resulted in Kudo Guinea being a
far more intelligent nomu than any of
the other know who were created from
corpses that's just my own personal
speculation at this point but now back
to the high and no mo while the high and
no mo are definitely far more
intelligent than the other no mo
the female no mo in particular seems to
be in a league of her own when it comes
to intelligence soon after she awakens
from her container we see that the
female normal is far more intelligent
than even some of the other high-end
normal like for example hood through her
inner monologue we are able to see that
she is just as intelligent as a highly
intelligent human if we didn't already
know that these were the inner thoughts
of animal we could easily have believed
that she was a human for example the way
that she was able to quickly figure out
the nature and effects of iowa's quirk
and then strategize accordingly tells me
that there is something special about
this nomal and all of this got me
thinking what if the female gnome was
intelligence is a clue that just like
with kudo Giri there is something
special about the female normal what if
she was also created from someone who is
somehow important to the story just like
Oboro was important to Aizawa and
present Mike and which human female with
an athletic body is important to the
story has come into contact with all
four one and is currently believed to be
dead the answer is of course Nana
Shimura the former user of one for all
the former master of all might and the
paternal grandmother of shigaraki Nana
is believed to have been killed by
all-4-one sometime after she passed on
the quirk to her successor all might but
the same was believed about Oboro until
we learned the dark truth so what if
Nana wasn't killed or even if she was
killed what if her corpse was used to
eventually create
the female nomu as I said earlier my
personal theory is that Oboro wasn't
dead when he was turned into kudo Giri
and that is why kudo getty is so much
more intelligent than a regular nomu
even though he was created so many years
ago
if creating highly intelligent nomal was
so easy that huge ego and all-4-one have
been successfully doing it for like
fourteen years then why even bother
creating all those a mindless nomu who
are much weaker than the intelligent
ones the only explanation that i can
think of is that most of the nomal are
made from corpses and this makes them
mindless zombies but a no move that is
made from a living person rather than a
corpse is more intelligent however it is
of course much harder to get your hands
on a live subject than a corpse and that
is why intelligent normal like kudo
giddy are so rare again this is just my
personal speculation it may turn out to
be true and it may not so with that in
mind what if naina Shimura wasn't
actually killed by all for one what if
everyone was just led to believe that
she was like with Oberoi but in reality
her body was used to create the female
nomal I think that she got Aki's recent
procedure proves that these types of
operations can be performed on living
people and not just on corpses but even
if you do believe that all nomu come
from corpses and you don't accept my
live subject theory could it be that
after naina was killed by all-4-one
would you call aunt
all-4-one got a hold of her corpse just
like they got a hold of Oberoi and they
then used her corpse to create the
female normal after the whole kudo giddy
Oboro reveal we know that something like
this is not impossible although it is
still of course unlikely I probably
wouldn't have made this video at all
despite all the comments if it wasn't
for a major possible clue that we got in
Chapter 270 of the manga a clue that may
support the Nana she muna is the female
normal theory a theory that I like to
call the Nana Nomura theory yes it's
cringe I know but I like it anyway
in Chapter 270 it was revealed that she
got aki has just inherited
the original all-4-one quirk from
all-4-one himself
all-4-one currently has a copy of his
own quirk while shigaraki now has the
original in chapter 270 we see shigaraki
or shigga Rocky's consciousness in a
chaotic dreamworld of sorts with
disembodied hands and rubble floating
around everywhere now we all know what
Shigure Aki's original villian costume
used to be he had 14 disembodied hands
covering different parts of his body all
fourteen hands apparently came from
people that shigaraki had killed who gqo
seemingly took their hands in bombed
them and then used them to create chigi
Rocky's outfit the owners of the hands
were members of Chicago Keyes family
that he had accidentally killed
including his sister mother and his
mother's parents the owners also
included two randos that shigaraki had
killed on the street and finally she got
Rocky's father's hands
well actually the hand that covers
chigan Aki's face belonged to his father
but his father's other hand had been
destroyed by shigaraki so because of
this the last remaining hand the one on
the very top of Shiga Rocky's head was
added by Yuko to make the costume
complete but we never really found out
where this other hand the one on the top
of his head actually came from was it
the hand of just a random individual was
it an artificial hand or was there more
to the story now back to chapter 270 in
this chapter there is a scene in which
she got his family is trying to stop him
from walking towards all-4-one all of
his family members are there his sister
mother maternal grandparents his father
and they are all holding shigaraki at
the same exact spots where their
disembodied hands had been holding his
old costume so then what about that hand
on the top of his head the hand that
seemingly didn't belong to anyone in
particular in Chapter 270 that very spot
is occupied by the hand of Nana she Mura
herself Nana is of course part of she
Rocky's family she is his father's
mother but as far as we know she got a
key
even met Nana she abandoned his father
when he was young in order to protect
him from the dangers of the pro-hero
life and she presumably died at the
hands of all four one before she got Aki
was even born so why would non up here
now inside this dreamlike vision and
grab that spot at the top of shigaraki
head it could all just be symbolic these
are all members of chika Rocky's family
and they're trying to stop him from
embracing all for one
his evil mentor who is like an adoptive
father to him and that's definitely a
possibility but what if this isn't just
symbolic what if this is a clue that the
mysterious hand on the top of Shikha
Rocky's head the one that didn't come
from any other member of his family
actually came from Nana shamone his
grandmother
what if after either killing Nana or
gravely injuring her all-4-one used her
body to create a female nomu but he
chose to keep one of Nonna's hands for
whatever reason that same hand was later
used for Shiga Rocky's villain costume
without him even realizing who it had
actually belonged to eventually in
Chapter 270 all of shigar Aquis family
is disintegrated inside the dream world
including notably Nana she muna as
shigaraki embraces all for one and then
another interesting thing happens at the
very end of chapter 270 at the same
moment that she got rocky finally
awakens Deku has a strong gut feeling or
premonition Deku looks extremely
disturbed he stops in his tracks and he
says he's coming we can assume that this
premonition or gut feeling comes from
Decca's connection to one for all and we
know that Nana's quark factor is still
inside one for all so Deku is connected
to Nana but was this just some sort of
psychic premonition that Deku had as a
result of one for all or did this
feeling come from Nana herself if nana
really is the female normal perhaps a
part of her is still in there somewhere
just like some part of Oboro still seems
to be inside of Kudo geenie
and since the female Nomo is currently
in the exact same location as the newly
awakened shigaraki maybe no moon Ana was
able to send some sort of signal to her
own quirk factor inside of one for all
and so that is why dec who suddenly had
such a strong gut feeling that borders
on a psychic premonition I may be
looking too much into that aspect of
chapter 270 and to be fair this entire
theory may just be based on looking too
much into certain details in the story
but it is definitely an intriguing
theory nonetheless if it's somehow ended
up being true that nana was used to
create the female normal this would make
the whole kuru Giri reveal just a
warm-up act to the main event the reveal
of naina Nomura
I mean imagine how all might would feel
if he found out that not only that all
for one kill his master he actually used
her or her body to create a high and no
mu this would absolutely crush all might
and it would definitely push all might
to lose his cool as a result all for one
and shigaraki may be able to bait all
might into doing something reckless and
this would give them the opportunity to
actually kill the symbol of peace all
mites potential death has been a major
plot point in the story for a long time
and we know that if she gareki did ever
kill all night
this would signal the end of the hero
society as we know it it would usher in
a new Dark Age of the villains and it
would completely change Deku as a
character the boku no hero society would
never be the same again
and if the story really is heading in
this direction the death of all might at
the hands of shigaraki
it could all depend on the hidden truth
about nana and the female no mo it is a
crazy theory to be sure but with
horikoshi and boku no hero
you just never know let me know what you
guys think do you buy into the theory
that the female normal might actually be
Nana she Munna
or do you think that it was just a
random
person who was turned into this nomal do
you think that any aspect of this theory
is possible or do you believe that the
clues I discussed here were merely
coincidental or symbolic finally could
Nana or her memory somehow be used by
shigaraki and all for one to bait all
might and kill him at some point in the
future please share your thoughts down
in the comments below if you enjoyed
this video you want to see more boku no
hero content please leave a like to let
me know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification
bells to turn on all notifications you
really have to go through the trouble of
clicking that bell and selecting the
option that says all if you don't you're
gonna miss a lot of our videos even if
you're subscribed unfortunately that's
just how YouTube works you can also hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime opera patrons who make
videos like this one possible a very
special thank you to a friend a a
disciple of Lord Twigg o himself and I
can't forget our the one tear patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including ingrid ah a lull an atom of
the world steelers tyson qui dino
acquired respect pat a heffa Jonathan
King desi be Brandon Aviles Papa Smurf
Emperor otaku and Richie Martinez
finally thank you also to all our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings eldress Anatole Cassatt's
key on hell cruise I sparky 65 cricut XP
Ted no Ted Joe Stanton very gucci alicia
akhter animal a 69 jessica calif on dino
commune water bonnie parks so dr 12
rothwyn de hora emperor mitch loves
anime cynical Kraken and JC c walk up if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you please
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]